So what is a knowledge representation? The collage on this
screen shows several knowledge representations that AI has developed. In each
knowledge representation there is a language. That language has a vocabulary.
Then, in addition to that language, in that knowledge representation there's
some content. The content of some knowledge. Let's take an example with which
you're probably already familiar. Consider the Newton's second law of motion.
So I can represent it as f is equal to m a. This is a knowledge representation.
A very simple knowledge representation, in which there are two things.
There is a language of algebraic equations, y s equal to b x, for
example. And then there is the content of our knowledge of
Newton's second law of motion, force equals mass times acceleration.
So the knowledge representation has two things, once again.
The language, which has its vocabulary. For example, this sign of equality. And
the content that goes into that representation expressed in that language.
Let us not worry too much about all of the representations in
this collage right now, we'll get to them later. The idea here is to
simply show that AI has developed not one, but many knowledge representations.
Each representation has its own affordances and its own constraints.